pas de 3g pour savoir qui est le plus
poissard de tous
à chaque fois vous allez voir deux
personnes vont s'affronter venir là
devant et s'affronter y aura de vente e
regardez bien la maison deux objets en
apparence si d'autres identique sauf que
l'un est piégée et l'autre non d'engins
des shots au nom il y a un petit jus de
tomate sympathique
dans l'autre choc il y a de la harissa
non enfin du tabasco c'est pareil quoi
c'est l'horreur c'est l'horreur c'est
les cas qui alloue qui a loué la mousse
à raser
adam c'est thomas thomas j'ai besoin de
vous photo marc thomas je vais vous
mettre de la mousse à raser dans une des
neuf de vos deux mains de dos voilà
comme ça et les filles vont choisir une
dès demain et vous ferez le bonjour de
la pieuvre soit sans mousse soit avec
mousse
m
c
les à la moins chanceuses
vous allez tous les deux appuyez
ensemble sur l'interrupteur de se ses
cheveux l'un est branché l'autre non
donc non sera temps de farine et lui
honoré non
so logique à 2 3 go non mais c'est comme
ça les vaut lalalalalalalalala l'agilité
[Musique]
tu es là
en clair ça c'est quoi ces désastres aux
séquences où le monde est salée le truc
est en train de fumer
qu'est-ce qui va alors là alors les
filles annoncé à un sceau du coin génial
c'est mon préféré regarde pas de nom
comme ça qu'on a envie de bien qu'on ait
une vie de merde où notre vie des otages
[Musique]
le but du jeu c'était vous avez un seau
avec quelque chose dedans
l'autre sauce en rien et elle devait à
la veuve se jeter à la place de la paix
de l'assiette mais c'était pour une
fille comme une espèce de petite
surprise qu est un piège donc voilà
alors nadège c'est foutu allez abonde un
jour un thème
4' quatre candidats quelle joie sarr qui
sera le plus poissard des cadres avant
le méga giga 3
ces reliques
non
en fait rien de me poussera d'amour sur
ma voie et c'est eric drogue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]